willkommen bei philo cast die jetzige
sendung geht über das thema studium im
ausland
was ist die message die wir mit diesem
video übermitteln was sagt einfach mal
lohnt sich ein auslandsstudium ja ganz
klare ansage ganz klare botschaft masse
ja okay meine empfehlung ist unbedingt
ins ausland zu gehen während des
studiums jetzt sei es jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht im bachelorstudium aber im
masterstudium würde ich das ja dazu
raten oder wenn man eine doktorarbeit
danach noch anstrebt eben im rahmen der
dissertation ein jahr möglichst ins
ausland in der branche die situation im
rahmen des master studiums vielleicht
ein halbes jahr aber auch im jahr ist
hier sehr gut ja und warum was bringt
mir das als student oder doktorand also
die vorteile sind vielfältig es gibt so
viele vorteile ich fange einfach mal ein
paar andere erzählen hätte
allein schon dass man mal eine andere
studiensituation kennenlernen nicht
immer nur an seiner universität ist die
universität mal wechselt dann dass meine
sprache viel besser beherrscht wenn man
zum beispiel eine nordamerikanische
universität geht dort sind die
universitäten mit am besten da empfehle
ich auch besonders hin zum selbst war es
ja auch die frage stand dort ist war
schon in chicago in pittsburgh und so
also das empfiehlt sich sehr sich eine
gute amerikanische universität
auszusuchen oder ebene universität zu
der partnerschaftliche verhältnisse
bestehen also austausch verhältnisse von
der lmu da gibt es hier sehr gute taten
universitäten
da sich einfach mal frühzeitig
erkundigen sprache kann man sehr gut
lernen wenn man lernt sehr interessante
studenten kennen aus allen möglichen
bereichen der welt und häufig hat man
mit diesen studenten danach noch längere
zeit kontakt also es gibt extrem viele
vorteile und in der regel kostet es
nicht es gibt stipendien erasmus oder
sie werden einmal lassen die
studiengebühren durch diese
partnerschaft ja und wir haben ja ein
video über berufsperspektiven in der
philosophie gedreht gibt es da auch
irgendwelche vorteile aus dem studium
würdest du sagen weil ich also wenn man
das jetzt in den lebenslauf schon
schreibt das macht sie immer gut wenn
man sie ja der studieren die studentin
und flexibel sie schaut über den
tellerrand
heraus sie ist mobil das macht sie immer
sehr gut auch nicht zuletzt was die
kompetenzen anbelangt man gerät mit
einer anderen kultur in kontakt man
verbessert seine sprache man hat mal
anderes kennengelernt in der unbedingt
ok ja vielen dank also das erasmus
angeht werden wir auch noch eine folge
drehen wahrscheinlich über die
bürokratischen aspekte dass man sich
frühzeitig bewirbt ich selbst mache das
gerade auch paris und da gibt es auch
einige interessante infos die ihr sicher
sein wollt dann verabschieden wir uns
und sehen uns bei in der nächsten folge
von 4cast torchance